bonjour à toutes et à tous et valeo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux alors ce mois de septembre a été
très très très excitant nous sommes
maintenant en octobre donc il est temps
de faire un bilan sur les actualités de
septembre ce mois de septembre donc a
été vraiment très excitant en matière de
découverte la première d'entre elles est
certainement l'une des plus marquantes
celle annonces faites dans vos
sibérienne times donc l'équivalent du
times du journal times en sibérie de de
la découverte donc d'un ours des
cavernes complètement préservée dans la
glace donc le pergélisol sibérien qui
préserve des mammouths et récemment on y
a même découvert des bébés lions des
lion des cavernes et bien maintenant
vient de nous donner ce premier spécimen
complet d'ours des cavernes complètement
préservée gelés dans le pergélisol
sibérien et vous voyez la conservation
est magnifique en face à vraiment une
bonne tête d'ours pour le coup et il ya
même un bébé ours qui a été découvert
non loin de là où on a découvert
l'adulte alors c'est pas le bébé de sept
adultes là ils n'ont pas été retrouvés
directement ensemble mais ils ont été
retrouvés à peu près dans la même dans
le même coin de la iakoutie donc cette
province au nord est extrême nord-est de
la sibérie
donc voyez c'est sur les bords des
rivières
donc pendant que le pergélisol font en
fait est que la rivière érode le board
le bord du pergélisol sur ses berges
c'est là que se trouvent tous et ses
mammouths ces rhinocéros laineux ont 6
ans qu'on a trouvé on a trouvé des
chevaux aussi faux gelée de cette façon
mais donc là c'est la première fois
qu'on retrouve un ours gelé dans ce père
gillison alors la date de cet animal
pour l'instant elle n'est pas il n'est
pas daté vraiment de façon
carbone 14 quoi ils ont pas encore eu le
temps de faire une datation au carbone
14 dessus mais en gros il daterait de
22000 à 39 milan d'après la formation
géologique où on ne trouve donc il
faudra voir
il faudra voir avec le carbone 14 ce que
cette date donne si ça confirme l'agent
en question on peut tout à fait date et
ça au carbone 14 puisque c'est des
tissus c'est des tissus organiques donc
très riches en carbone et on va
certainement apprendre beaucoup beaucoup
de choses avec cet animal on sait pas
encore ce qu'il en retourne puisque
effectivement ceci berriane times n'est
pas un journal scientifique donc il faut
il faut raison garder quand même face à
sète à cette annonce de sibérienne times
n'est pas un journal scientifique c'est
juste un journal c'est juste un journal
normal quoi c'est comme le monde le
figaro bref c'est juste un journal c'est
donc une annonce très très très
préliminaires c'est juste une annonce
qui dit on a trouvé un ours des cavernes
voilà et c'est tout et même là dessus va
falloir prendre des pincettes parce que
sur twitter évidemment il ya eu des
réactions
donc encore une fois c'est pas publier
ces réactions c'est juste sur twitter
mais sur twitter il ya eu des réactions
très très pertinentes quant à l'identité
de ses sources notamment des gens qui
ont dit que possiblement il s'était
peut-être un peu jeté enfin c'était
peut-être jeté un peu vite sur
l'identification en tant que l'ours des
cavernes
notamment parce que voici donc enfin
voici la distribution de ursus spelaeus
donc l'ours des cavernes et d'autres
ours qui vivait à la même époque que
l'ours des cavernes en asie en eurasie
donc l'ours des cavernes on le trouve en
espagne on trouve en france évidemment
on en trouve aussi un petit peu vous
voyez dans dans le plus à l'est dans les
régions tempérées donc c'est une espèce
qui vivaient plutôt en régions tempérées
donc le trouvez ci haut
enfin le trouver en sibérie déjà c'est
un peu surprenant
et quand on regarde du cou où se trouve
le site où cet ours des cavernes a été a
été découvert cet ours veut geler et là
il est complètement vrai à l'extrême
nord-est de la sibérie donc c'est sûr
c'est non loin d'eux
je me demande même si c'est pas
directement sur l'île de wrangel donc là
où survécu les derniers mahmoud si c'est
pas l'île de wrangel directement c'est
vraiment juste à côté quoi c'est pas
loin et donc ces voix là c'est pas du
tout dans la dans la zone de
distribution de l'ours des cavernes qui
quand je le disais à une distribution
plus tôt beaucoup plus basse au final
donc un climat qui est quand même un peu
plus un peu plus agréable bon après
comme je disais ça dépend aussi de l'âge
puisque à la fin de la période du
dernier maximum glaciaire l'île de
rangueil c'était à peu près le seul
endroit où il y avait encore un climat
où la faune ou la mégafaune glaciaire
pouvait encore survivre donc ça va
beaucoup aussi dépendre de l'âge mais
sachant que le spécimen est datée entre
donc ce qu'ils nous disaient dans le
cyber yan tan c'était entre 40000 enfin
entre 39 milles et 22 mille ans on est
loin de la fin du mois du dernier
maximum glaciaire la fin du dernier
maximum glaciaire c'est entre 15000 et
dix mille ans et c'est là justement que
il est que l'ours des cavernes a disparu
donc il y as entre 22000 et 40000 en cet
endroit là le au nord de la sibérie
on se peler les miches voilà donc il
faut raison garder face à tafas à 7 face
à cette annonce
un ours des cavernes ce serait super
cool un ours brun ce serait bien aussi
loin d'ours polaires pourquoi pas ce
serait bien aussi
d'autant que je crois pas qu'on est des
masses de fossiles d'ours polaires pour
le coup ou une de ces espèces là il
gressus soudé nincheri par exemple ce
serait cool aussi
d'ailleurs il y aurait plus de chances
que ce soit denim jerry puisque c'est le
seul qu'on trouve dans cette région là à
l'état de fossiles
donc si c'est un ours des cavernes c'est
la première fois qu'on retrouve à l'ours
des cavernes aussi loin donc il faut il
faut voir ce que ça va donner
donc analyses au carbone 14 pour savoir
l'âge de ce fossile
enfin de cette carcasse et analyses adn
pour savoir exactement l'identité de cet
animal puisque de l'adn d'ours d'ours
des cavernes
nous en avons nous en au moins de l'adn
mitochondrial du moins donc ça de l'adn
d'ours des cavernes on en a même si on
n'en n'avait jamais retrouvé avant gelé
dans le
gili sol on a quand même quelques
spécimens en europe qui ont donné deux
un peu d'adn mitochondrial et extraits
directement des dents fossiles donc on
pourra identifier de quoi il s'agit donc
pour l'instant restons prudents ce n'est
toujours pas publié dans une revue à
comité de lecture mais ça ne saurait
tarder du moins on l'espère que d'ici
d'ici un ou deux ans on en saura plus à
propos de cet ours des cavernes
l'autre grosse news ça a été la
découverte d'un nouveau coelacanthe une
nouvelle espèce de celle à quand donc le
coelacanthe c'est ce fameux gros
poissons dont on dit qu'il est un
fossile vivant et bien voici une
nouvelle étude qui démontre que non le
coelacanthe n'est pas du tout un fossile
vivant déjà c'est au moins trois
fossiles vivants donc une espèce qui vit
sur au large des côtes sud africaines
une espèce qui vit en indonésie donc
voici la distribution des coelacanthe
donc avant cette cette étude la
publication de cette étude on
connaissait une espèce qui vivait au
large des côtes sud africaines
on connaissait une espèce qui vivait en
indonésie et maintenant on vient de
découvrir une seconde espèce qui vient
en indonésie qui n'a pas encore reçu de
nom officiel parce qu'elle n'est connue
pour l'instant que par un spécimen donc
le coelacanthe c'est pas un fossile
vivant déjà c'est trois espèces et ce ne
sont pas du tout des fossiles vivants
puisque maintenant qu'on peut
reconstituer un arbre évolutif des
coelacanthe là avec trois espèces voici
à quoi il ressemble cet arbre évolutif
et donc on voit que le coelacanthe enfin
que les coelacanthe déjà sont apparus au
carbonifère donc la grande famille des
coelacanthe apparaît au carbonifère là
on a tout un tas de faux cils donc qui
sont manquants et que donc les
coelacanthe moderne
eux ils datent pas du tout du
carbonifère vous voyez que la divergence
des espèces de coelacanthe moderne donc
ici vous avez les sud-africains et ici
vous avez les deux espèces indonésienne
dont la nouvelle espèce ici qui est ici
ils ont leurs numéros ils ont leur petit
code-barres c'est leur numéro de
spécimens mais bon voilà ici c'est celle
un cantat denaisiens nouvelle espèce
indonésienne et c'est là qu'en de sud
africains et leurs ancêtres en commun
vivait au milieu du cénozoïque c'est à
dire que quand on vous dit que le
coelacanthe est une relique du temps des
dinosaures
l'ancêtre en commun des espèces modernes
de coelacanthe n'a jamais vu le moindre
dinosaures les dinosaures
enfin n'a jamais vu le moindre
dinosaures non aviens évidemment encore
que pour voir des oiseaux là où ville
c'est là quand c'est un peu compliqué
mais bref les dinosaures c'est anissi
non aviens c'est là qu'ils s'éteignent
et voici où apparaissent les coelacanthe
moderne milieu du cénozoïque 1 donc les
laisser là quand sont pas plus vieux que
la plupart des espèces du genre de
mammifères modernes donc déjà ça faut
quand même bien seul enfoncer dans le
crâne fossile vivant kaka on arrête
d'appeler le coelacanthe le fossile
vivant et on arrête même de dire le
coelacanthe il ya trois espèces de celle
à quand maintenant dont une qui n'est
pas encore qui n'a pas encore été
officiellement nommé et elle n'a pas été
officiellement nommé parce qu'il ya
quinze spécimens comme je le disais tout
à l'heure et que ce spécimen apparemment
il est bien il s'est fait charcuter
littéralement puisqu'apparemment il a
été pêché pour être bouffé donc il a un
peu été changée en steak donc déjà on
apprend au passage que le coelacanthe
que le coelacanthe est comestible
enfin que manger du coelacanthe c'est
possible et d'autre part on apprend
aussi que que du coup les découvertes
scientifiques se font beaucoup sur les
étals de bouchers
mais ça c'est quelque chose que j'avais
déjà présenté dans ma vidéo sur la
cryptozoologie donc voila et 7 et vous
voyez donc que ici vous avez donc cette
nouvelle espèce indonésienne comparé aux
coelacanthe indonésien et là on a un âge
de divergence calculée entre les deux
qui est d'environ 12 à 13 millions
d'années donc 12 à 13 millions d'années
c'est plus que ce qui nous sépare des
chimpanzés assez quasiment deux fois
plus de temps que ce qui nous sépare des
chimpanzés donc au cas où vous vous
demandiez bras c'est juste un autre
coelacanthe indonésien non non c il ya
vraiment une distance génétiques entre
ces coelacanthe indonésien qui est
gigantesque donc et tout ça ça nous
apprend au final que laisser là quand
ils ont connu une radiation évolutive au
cénozoïque donc une grande
diversification cénozoïque
ce qui est complètement le contraire de
ce qu'on devrait voir chez ce qu'on
appellerait un fossile vivant non là on
arrête d'appeler le coelacanthe un
fossile vivant maintenant on dit laissez
là quand et les coelacanthe sont très
diversifiés et je souligne au passage
que c'est une découverte qui a été fait
avec des chercheurs français
donc voyez ici david mouillot emmanuel
paradis par exemple qui nous viennent de
l'institut des sciences de l'évolution
de montpellier et de l'ifremer de
montpellier donc on leur dit bravo et on
leur dit un grand merci pour cette belle
découverte
l'article suivant c'est un article un
peu plus controversée qui a c'est un
article que vous n'avez peut-être pas vu
passer alors c'est aussi dans la revue
scientifique report comme pour le
coelacanthe donc revues scientifiques
report qui qui est une succursale de
deutscher donc du prestigieux magazine
deutscher donc bon c'est quand même à
prendre au sérieux mais celui-là il a
été quand même un peu plus controversé
c'est un article qui donc pour la
première fois enfin qui a été vendue
comme étant la première reconstruction
précise de l'anatomie deux autobus
megalodon donc le fameux megalodon donc
ça voilà à peu près la silhouette qu'il
reconstruise pour autobus megalodon est
la grande question c'est comment il
arrive à ce résultat
et c'est là qu'il ya controverse bon
déjà il ya controverse parce que ça a
été vendu comme étant ça y est on sait
enfin à quoi ressemblait megalodon non
on sait toujours pas à quoi ressemble
megalodon là pour le coup les bains
s'est une fois de plus les services de
communication les médias qui se sont un
peu emballé non on ne sait pas à quoi
ressemblait megalodon ils ont fait une
estimation à partir d'une observation
relativement simple qui est que
megalodon est un l'âme ni forme donc
c'est un requin qui appartient à la
famille d'elham ni forme et les lames
uniforme de grande taille
ils ont tous à peu près la même tronche
donc si on arrive
grosso modo à quantifier comment qu'on
arrive à quantifier la forme la
silhouette générale de célèbres
uniformes et vous voyez c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait là à partir de ce qu'on appelle
des landes marx
utiliser des points de repère et ils ont
utilisé des méthodes statistiques pour
reconstituer voilà les principaux
éléments de la silhouette voyez
l'aileron dorsal vous voyez là que tout
ça ils ont utilisé à mais un protocole
statistiques pour arriver à reconstituer
les principaux les principales parties
du corps de megalodon à partir de se
concéder la mini forme moderne et
partant de là il propose cette hypothèse
et cette hypothèse vous voyez il ya
encore ici tout un tas de mesures qui
ont été faites et à part sur les lames
ni forme moderne et à partir de ça il
extrapole au megalodon voilà donc ça
c'est une hypothèse faite à partir de
l'observation des lames ni forme moderne
on a tous une on n'a toujours aucune
idée de ce à quoi ressemblait megalodon
donc là les couleurs c'est pareil c'est
la fin c'est pas de la fantaisie l'ont
ils ont raisonnablement fait l'hypothèse
qu'il y avait un ce qu'on appelle un
conteur shading donc une ombre un nombre
âge contraire à savoir que c'est le
dessus qui est plus sombre que le
dessous parce que quand on est dans
l'eau quand les animaux nous voient du
dessous on est blanc et quand les
animaux vous voit du dessus on est noir
et c'est vachement plus pratique c'est
vachement plus pratique pour le
camouflage d'avoir ce genre de contre
ombrage je ne suis pas complètement sûr
de comment on traduit kunter shading
peut-être que si quelqu'un sait il peut
l'écrire dans les commentaires ça
m'aidera beaucoup ça augmentera ma
culture mais voilà donc ils font une
hypothèse raisonnable de ce à quoi
ressemblait megalodon et le problème que
les gens vont le problème que les gens
ont eu avec ça parce qu'il ya vraiment
des sceaux de merde qui ont été
déversées sur cet article
c'est que c'est que c'est que ça a été
survendue en fait ça a été survendue
comme ça y est on sait à quoi ressemble
megalodon bon on le sait pas voici une
hypothèse elle demandera à être testé
dans le futur quand on découvrira un
jour peut-être pourquoi pas un squelette
complet megalodon voire même pourquoi
pas encore mieux des tissus mous de
megalodon préserver ce n'est pas demain
la veille que ça arrivera probablement
mais qui sait qui c'est qui sait il ya
bien il me semble qu'il ya bien un privé
un chercheur de fossiles privé qui
prétend avoir un squelette de megalodon
complet donc ça se trouve ça existe un
voilà mais c'est juste une hypothèse
basée sur des mesures sur des stats
voilà c'est pas c'est pas une découverte
nouvelle on va dire c'est juste des
juste une hypothèse et au final cette
hypothèse n'est pas vilaine puisqu'on
arrive à une taille estimée de megalodon
de 16 m donc ça reste raisonnablement
dans les clous de ce qui avait été déjà
proposée récemment donc ça ne méritait
pas de se prendre les sauts de merde qui
s'y sont pris sur la gueule c'est voilà
c'est tout c'est ces jeux c'est joli
c'est joli c'est élégant et puis bon bah
après c'est pas factuel quoi voilà c'est
hypothétique
on continue avec une découverte qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup secoué moi et j'avais
envie de le partager avec vous c'est la
découverte du chromosome y de néandertal
parce que j'ai appris avec cet article
qu'on n'avait jamais vu de chromosome y
de néandertal donc déjà on s'assoit un
tranquille ça fait déjà plus de dix ans
maintenant qu'on connaît le génome
entier de néandertal on vient seulement
de découvrir le chromosome y
donc jusqu'à présent c'est ce qui en
raconte là dedans dans cet article
jusqu'à présent ce qu'on avait découvert
c'était quasiment que des femelles ou
alors on a trouvé des mâles mais le
génome n'était pas suffisamment bien
préservés pour vous pour lire le
chromosome y
donc c'est la première fois qu'on arrive
à séquencer les gènes du chromosome y de
néandertal et ça c'est où ça déjà c'est
ouf parce que je savais même pas moi
qu'on ne l'avait pas le chromosome y de
néandertal donc vous imaginez que toutes
ces hypothèses qu'on a pu le faire par
ci et par là
surkis et hybrides et avec qui est ce
que c'est des mâles néandertal avec des
femelles humaines ou des femelles
humaine avec des mâles néandertal tout
ça c'était sans savoir à quoi
ressemblait le chromosome y de
néandertal donc autant dire j'ai pas
envie de dire que c'était du pipeau
c'était pour moi c'étaient des
hypothèses raisonnables avec les données
accessibles à l'époque mais autant dire
que maintenant qu'on sait à quoi le le
chromosome y de néandertal ressemblent
autant dire que c'était quand même d'un
grand coup de dés voilà c'était c'était
vraiment un grand coup de dés un grand
coup de vent va voir si ça marche ou si
ça marche pas quoi et donc maintenant la
le chromosome y est ce qu'ils ont
découvert ce qui est assez formidable
donc déjà ils ont pas qu'un seul
néandertal ils ont réussi à en avoir
plusieurs puisque est plutôt cool ils
l'ont comparé à denisova et l'ont
comparé à homo sapiens est donc ce
qu'ils ont découvert c'est que le
chromosome y
des hommes de néanderthal ici en bleu
n'est pas proche de celui des
denisovians comme on pourrait s'y
attendre parce que normalement
néandertal et denisot va sont très
proches parents je veux dire tout le
reste de leur génome nous crient qu'ils
sont proches parents mais non le
chromosome y lui de néandertal il est
plus proche de celui de homo sapiens et
sari s'y attendait pas du tout
ce qui veut dire selon eux qu en gros
vous avez la branche qui mène à homo
sapiens
vous l'avez l'amant la branche qui mène
à néanderthal et à denisova est le
chromosome y en fait lui ce qu'il a fait
c'est qu'il a pris la branche homo
sapiens et il aurait sauté à néandertal
à un moment il y as entre il ya entre
eux ils disent alors ce qu'ils disent
c'est qu'il ya entre 100000 et 300 mille
ans donc déjà homo sapiens était pas
forcément sorti d'afrique à l'époque
donc on sait pas trop comment ça se
serait fait mais en gros il ya entre
100000 et 300 mille ans homo sapiens et
néandertal aurait aurait fait des
enfants ensemble et le chromosome y
ce serait transmis à néandertal donc
voilà il y aurait eu il y aurait eu
quéquette et il y aura eu transfert du
chromosome y a une population de
néandertaliens qui l'aurait ensuite
et là c'est là qu'il faut s'accrocher ça
il y aurait eu un événement
d'hybridation qui aurait transmis le
chromosome y à néandertal qui aurait
ensuite transmis ce chromosome
enfin une petite population de
néandertal qui aurait ensuite transmis
ce chromosome à tous les autres
néandertaliens donc on sait pas à quelle
vitesse a eu lieu on sait pas dans
quelles conditions ça a eu lieu on sait
pas non plus on sait pas non plus
pourquoi ce chromosome y d'un seul coup
se serait répandu dans la population
enfin je veux dire il aurait dû se il
aurait dû gentiment se diluer en fait ce
chromosome y
et il sait pas qu'il sait pas gentiment
dilué il s'est complètement répandue est
devenu le chromosome dominante donc le
chromosome y est devenu le même que
celui d' homo sapiens de l'époque notre
chromosome y est encore différent de
celui de l'homo sapiens dit à 310 lien
entre 300000 et sans milan 1 c'est pas
le même que ce que le chromosome y qu'on
a aujourd'hui mais en gros voilà l'idée
voilà la grosse idée c'est qu'il y
aurait eu un événement d'hybridation
dont on n'avait aucune idée jusqu'à
présent qui a eu lieu à une époque où on
savait pas que homo sapiens et
néandertal pouvait se fréquenter et
pourtant eh ben ça a marché quand même
donc évidemment comme ce scénario est
moyennement satisfaisant il propose
quand même un scénario alternatif un
scénario alternatif qui est que en fait
c'est le chromosome y de denisova qui
vient de ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
poli
morphisme de base c'est à dire qu'en
gros denisot va hériter d'un chromosome
y qui est très primitif issue en fait
d'un polymorphisme du chromosome y qui
était présent chez l'ancêtre en commun
de denisova néandertal et l'homo sapiens
et dans ce cas-là ça expliquerait aussi
pourquoi le chromosome de denisova est
si différent en fait dans la dentelle
dans le scénario alternatif
voilà pour enlever tout le jargon on va
on va la refaire sans jargon en gros au
lieu de dire que c'est néandertal est
homo sapiens qui ont le même chromosome
y
le scénario alternatif c'est de dire
qu'en fait c'est denisova qui est un
chromosome y super différents
et que celui de néandertal et du coup
celui de néandertal et sapiens
paraissent être vachement similaire
alors qu'ils ne sont pas spécialement
c'est juste que c'est denisova qui est
complètement pété voilà et ce à la
limite
au niveau du registre fossile ça colle
un peu mieux mais bon je rappelle quand
même que denisot va on en sait que dalle
à part ces gènes on sait rien de denisot
va on a très très peu de matériel
fossile donc je rappelle juste que le
registre fossile il a aussi ses lacunes
et que bon donc on verra ce que dit le
futur à propos de ça est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant aussi sur cette image je
vais résumer un petit peu pour qu'on
voit mieux mais il ya aussi l'adn
mitochondrial qui représentait en forme
de rond mais l'adn mitochondrial donc
lui il est transmis de façon
matrilinéaire c'est à dire qu'il est
transmis par la mère et donc on voit
qu'il ya aussi des échanges des adn
mitochondriaux entre tous et entre tous
ces gens donc il ya à la fois des mâles
et des femelles sapiens et non sapiens
qui se sont abrités dans tous les sens
c'est formidable c'est grandiose c'était
la grande partouze du pléistocène la gpp
la grande partouze pléistocène
j'ai un copyright sur cette expression
si vous tombez si vous voulez la
réutiliser je le saurai mais c'est super
intéressant comme découverte et puis ben
voilà c'est une décennie c'est ce genre
de découverte magnifique qui pose plus
de questions que de réponses et veut
dire tu sors de là tu crois que tu
connais maintenant on connaît le gène de
les chromosomes
enfin maintenant on connaît le
chromosome y de néandertal tu crois
qu'on va résoudre tous les mystères du
monde
et ben non en fait le chromosome y de
néandertal il ressemble plus à celui de
sapiens et du coup ça fout la merde
c'est prodigieux
c'est prodigieux moi j'adore sans
transition on part on part vers mes
petits chéris il était rapide
les thérapies ciblées ce qu'on appelait
autrefois est ce qu'on aimerait encore
appelé les reptiles malien j'aime mieux
le terme prémat malien bref ce sont les
ancêtres des mammifères qui vivait au
permien et au trias qui ne sont pas
encore des mammifères mais qui sont déjà
bien engagés sur cette voie
donc ces reptiles malien c'était rapide
ils ont survécu à la plus grande crise
biologique qui ait jamais eu lieu la
crise permien trias qui a eu lieu il ya
252 millions d'années
donc cette crise permien trias 90% des
espèces se sont éteintes mais les
ancêtres des mammifères ayant survécu
donc ces fameux prémat maliennes
notamment les sino donc il ya aussi les
ancêtres des dinosaures qui ont survécu
bah oui on est au début du trias
dinosaures doivent encore régner qui
sont encore appelé à régner donc les
thérapies side
ils sont vachement super parce qu'ils
ont survécu à la limite permise à trias
la grande question c'est comment ils ont
survécu à la permis au trias et là en
fait cet article qui nous vient d'une
équipe australienne nous rapporte la
découverte de cette section géologique
section géologiques où on voit la limite
permise trias donc limite permise trias
ici bon qui s'est pas comme la limite
crétacé tertiaire où on a une jolie
couche d'argile noir dans la limite
permise trias là on sait qu'elle est là
parce qu'il ya une excursion isotopique
vous voyez la géochimie de la roche donc
la chimie de la roche parce que
géochimie de la roche c'est un pléonasme
la chimie de la roche vous voyez indique
une énorme excursions carbone qui
indique qu'il ya eu une grosse
perturbation environnementale sept
grosses perturbations environnementales
c'est la crise permien trias est ici
donc on voit cette énorme excursion qui
se situe à cet endroit au niveau de la
roche est ici ce que vous voyez en jaune
et bien ce sont des terriers des
terriers de petits sino dont tu es vous
voyez donc ses terriers de sinnoh dans
qui sont creusées ici alors ce qu'on
voit ici c'est juste ce qu'il ya
l'affleurement mais ses terriers de 6,91
bien il indique que dessine au dont tu
étais présent non seulement avant mais
aussi après voyez qu'il ya des terriers
avant et des terriers après d'ailleurs
en fait en réalité n'en sais même pas
qui a des terriers avant et après c'est
qu'elle est terrier après mais qui
coupent dans la limite permise à trias
donc en fait c'est des terriers qui qui
montre qu'en fait les terriers se sont
vraiment fait juste après la limite
permise trias donc il recoupe la limite
permise trias ce qui suggère très
fortement que ces synodaux et bien ils
ont survécu à la limite permise trias
grâce à leur capacité à faire des
terriers ce qu'on supposait déjà être le
cas vous voyez la représentation ici
d'un de ses terriers
on voit ici en pointillés représenter
les traces de griffes de ces fameux de
ces fameux 6,90
donc c'est ce sont des petits fossile
très émouvant puisque on arrive même à
voir les traces d'activité des animaux
qui les ont faits
donc c'est vraiment super intéressant
comme découverte alors c'est que des
preuves circonstancielles évidemment ça
ne démontre pas que les synodaux ont
survécu grâce au fait qu'il faisait des
terriers mais même si c'est que
circonstancielle c'est quand même une
très forte suggestion que c'est bien la
capacité à faire des terriers qui les a
fait survivre
sachant que l'on pensait déjà ça avant
même d'avoir découvert ça je veux dire
c'était déjà l'hypothèse dominante que
c'était la capacité à faire des terriers
qui avait permis aux cylons donc de
survivre
pareil pour les listes rose or les
listes rose or on a beaucoup de preuves
que liste rose en était capable de faire
détaillé et liste rose or c'est aussi
une de ses mains c'est même une des
seules espèces
enfin des sols genre dont on sait qu'il
a traversé la limite permise trias donc
on pense qu'il ya pas de fumée sans feu
pour le coup et c'est une hypothèse
raisonnable et qui mérite d'être
explorée dans le futur en tout cas là
c'est la première preuve même si elle
n'est que circonstancielle c'est la
première preuve qu'en tout cas il y
avait des signaux donc qui durant la
limite permise trias faisait des
terriers on continue toujours dans le
trias avec maintenant là alors là non ce
qui alors ce qui a été annoncé on va
dire c'est la découverte d'une nouvelle
extinction de masse donc la fameux
sixième extinction de masse qui aurait
ce qui serait survenue à la fin du trias
et qui aurait ouvert la porte à la
diversification des dinosaures donc ce
qui a dû vous surprendre probablement
puisque jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant on
pensait que c'était plutôt l'extinction
trias sic jurassique patriat jurassique
qui avait permis la diversification des
dinosaures donc là de savoir qu'il y à
une extinction qui a eu lieu au quartier
donc c'est à dire au milieu on va dire
de la fin du trias ça repousse un petit
peu on va dire le face à des couples
l'extinction trias jurassique de la
diversification des dinosaures ça veut
dire que la diversification des
dinosaures a eu lieu avant la limite
trias jurassique donc et ça a été
annoncé comme étant la nouvelle
extinction de masse une nouvelle
extinction de masse vient d'être
découverte et c'est elle qui a permis
aux dinosaures de prendre leur envol
donc ça a été publiée dans science at 26
qui est au journal qui est au
prestigieux journal sayan ce que
scientific report est au prestigieux le
journal nature c'est une petite
sûr que succursale c1 c'est un petit
sous produits on va dire donc mais ça
reste assez prestigieux et on y retrouve
michael benton dans la liste des
coauteurs donc michael benton qui qui
est l'auteur de tous les livres sur les
dinosaures qui ont pu bercé votre
enfance
et s'il n'est pas s'il n'en est pas
l'auteur il y as forcément contribué et
si vous n'avez lu aucun livre dans
lequel il y avait des dinosaures dedans
vous avez forcément vu sur la terre des
dinosaures et il a été un des
conseillers scientifiques sur dents sur
la terre des dinosaures donc votre
enfant ça a été forcément bercé à un
moment ou à un autre par un produit
culturel issu plus ou moins de michael
benton
c'est vous dire le monsieur envoie du
lourd
voilà c'est juste là où je veux en venir
et donc cette nouvelle extinction au
carnet est déjà allé intéressante parce
qu'elle a lieu pendant ce que ce qu'on
appelle le cas reniant le quart nian
plus violent épisode donc l occar nian
pluviales épisode c'est en gros encore
une fois c'est une excursion isotopique
qu'on remarque que pendant le quart n'ya
donc c'est à dire il ya entre 234 et 232
millions d'années puisque c'est écrit là
donc c'est cette excursion isotopique ça
je crois que c'est un isotopes de
l'oxygène s'il me semble non d'ailleurs
il ya aussi des isotopes du carbone
d'après ce que je vois là donc bref
c'est un cetain c'est une excursion
isotopique qui indiquerait qu'en gros il
ya eu beaucoup d'eau douce par tous en
même temps et pendant très longtemps et
un tel apport d'eau douce ça peut pas
être juste une rivière puisqu'une
rivières ça reste quand même un
événement localiser même une inondation
ça reste un événement localiser donc
c'est forcément de l'autre pluie et
cette eau de pluie elle a donc changé
les ratios isotopique de la roche au
courant du canadien et ça a duré pendant
plusieurs millions d'années
voyez là le on est sur à peu près deux
millions d'années donc vous imaginez des
pluies torrentielles s'abattent en sueur
sur la terre pendant 2 millions d'années
alors le problème c'est qu'on voit pas
ce
cet épisode pluviales je crois ils n'ont
enregistré que en amérique du sud
si je ne me trompe pas peut-être en
europe du nord
mais voilà ils s'enregistrent pas
partout on va dire donc il y avait
quelques doutes sur est-ce que ce tv
pisode kahnien était vraiment aussi
généralisée que ça bon mais là en gros
ils ont l'air de ce qu'ils disent dans
cet article c'est que cet épisode
pluviales gardien s'accompagne aussi
d'une extinction donc une extinction au
niveau des des invertébrés donc ici vous
voyez des les hameaux no id par exemple
ici vous avez des cônes au dos qui sont
bons qui sont encore des invertébrés
bien qu'il soit plus proche des
vertébrés mais on va les mettre dans la
catégorie invertébrés juste pour faire
plus simple et qui ce qui s'accompagne
d'une extinction aussi au niveau des
eaux au niveau des plantes donc ici vous
avez benetti talent les l'hémato niasse
et je suis nul en paléobotanique
j'annonce tout de suite voilà les
fameuses vol diatta tenait les vols via
qu'on retrouve dans le trias d'europe
apparemment elles prennent cher en tout
cas on retrouve beaucoup moins de pollen
après qu'avant cet épisode car vient
donc épisode cardiaque ici souligné
surligné en rouge
d'ailleurs qui se trouve entre un étage
qui s'appelle le julien voilà et le tue
valiant bref
donc voici cet épisode pull vial voici
la fameuse excursions isotopique dont je
vous parlais d'ailleurs c'est un isotope
du carbone
voilà c'est confirmé donc excursions
isotopique au carbone courbe de paléo
température avec des variations de
température donc apparemment des
températures beaucoup plus chaude après
qu'avant l'épisode gardien et on a donc
ces extinctions de plantes on à
extinction de quelques invertébrés et on
a apparition vous voyez des dinosaures
pendant l'épisode carnières voyez qu
avant ça il ya quasiment pas de on
retrouve quasiment aucun dinosaures ou
de dinosaur y forme pour le coup et d'un
seul coup ils apparaissent au gardien et
deviennent relativement nombreux et
c'est aussi par là qu'apparaissent
certains crocodiles aux morts papa
crocodile au mof mai
arco the reform bardon comme les
philosophes les ce péno d'onde c'est
aussi là qu'ils vont prendre leur essor
bien qu'ils étaient là avant l'espé 90
ils vont commencer à prendre leur essor
et c'est peu de temps après ça en gros
que va se passer l'extinction des la
plupart des dt rap side et notamment des
dix innocentes qui avaient survécu et de
beaucoup d'autres groupes qui ne sont
pas des mammifères on va dire donc donc
ça coïncide parfaitement avec l'épisode
pluviales carnières mais ça ça participe
quand même apparemment donc voilà ce qui
se serait passé à cet épisode pluviales
quaregnon ballet petit reproche qu'on
peut faire là dessus c'est que c'est que
c'est que m'a déjà d'un parmi les îles
font on va dire que dans l'article ils
font vraiment une grosse fixation sur
les insectes
or le registre fossile des insectes
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on a deux de
plus riches et de plus comment dire
et de plus fiable que la lah au niveau
des vertébrés vous avez certainement
remarqué que c'était pas non plus enfin
il ya hockey le début de la
diversification des dinosaures il ya
hockey plus ou moins l'extinction d'aidé
d'ici 90 mais c'est pas non plus c'est
pas non plus absolu je veux dire l'iso
vie qu'il ya par exemple
l'iso vie qui a qui est le plus gros
d'ici n'ont donc jamais trouvé il vient
du nom rien si si je ne m'abuse donc
c'est un des tout derniers disent
innocente qui a survécu
donc dès encore dans le nord rien on
avait toujours des dédits sino dont tu
donc la corolle on va dire que la
corrélation est pas parfaite
vous avez des groupes dont qu'ils ont
ajouté dans ce graphique dont on n'a
rien niveau registre fossile donc les
tortues et les mammifères on n'a aucune
idée de ce qui se passe à ce niveau là
on a des points voilà on à odos tôt
kelis par exemple qui correspond aux
cars niamey est ce que ça veut dire
qu'ils étaient en voie de s'éteindre est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il était en voie
de diversification ne c'est pas pareil
pour les mammifères il parle pas des
synodes honte mais dessine aux dons
c'est pareil il se passe rien de
particulier au niveau des 6 90
et puis ben comme je disais vous avez
ici vous
les crocodiles imhoff les les fit aux
orres les six lots dont il ya c'est
pareil c'est pas trés trés la
coïncidence n'est pas flagrante
voilà on va dire donc est ce que est ce
que c'est vraiment tellement un épisode
d'extinction que ça appelez ça une
extinction de masse c'est peut-être un
peu fort
appelez ça l'événement qui a permis aux
dinosaures de se diversifier il y as
coïncidence yat-il corrélation
point d'interrogation voilà donc encore
une fois il faut être prudent par
rapport à ces effet d'annonce petite
découverte sympa maintenant enfin un
petit donc publié une fois de plus dans
sa haine anti-flic report de la revue
nature's c'est évidemment je ne peux pas
en parler sans vous donner l'impression
que ça enfonce une porte ouverte mais en
gros ça vous mot c'est une étude qui
montre que la plume d'archaeopteryx
appartient bien à archéoptéryx voilà
donc c'est dur à rendre
c'est dur à rendre exceptionnel comme
découverte dit comme ça mais en gros il
y avait sept premières plumes
d'archaeopteryx qui avait été là tout
tout tout tout première découverte au
milieu du 19e siècle qu'on a découvert
avant de découvrir les squelettes
donc c'est elle le spécimen qui est qui
sert de référence à archéoptéryx et
quand on a découvert donc les autres
spécimen d'archaeopteryx donc les
squelettes cette fois et bien on a
naturellement c'est naturellement dit
que la plume de vellerat pas retenir
donc c'est la même espèce
donc c'est archéoptéryx sauf que sauf
que ben peut-on dire réellement que
cette plume appartient à archéoptéryx eh
bien ils ont fait tout un tas d'études
donc notamment des démesures des
comparaisons avec les tous les spécimens
connu d'archaeopteryx sur lesquels les
plumes sont préservés donc vous avez
notamment le fameux spécimens de londres
si je me rappelle bien doit y avoir le
spécimen de berlin le spécimen de munich
de toute façon c'est écrit dessus un
londres london spécimens donc voilà le
spécimen de marcus berg donc tous ces
spécimens préserver le plus mais non
seulement ils ont pu dire oui cette
plume appartient bien archéoptéryx mais
en plus ils ont pu reconstituer
exactement à quel endroit elle sincère
et ça c'est quand même cool
bien c'est bon il n'y a pas de raison de
penser que cette plume appartient à
autre chose qu archéoptéryx et c'est une
question qui pouvait légitimement se
poser dans la mesure où certains
spécimen d'archaeopteryx ont été
attribués à des genres différents
donc certains lazare qu'est opté rixe ne
sont peut-être pas des archéoptéryx
d'ailleurs mais voilà donc sachez qu'il
ya encore beaucoup de débats là dessus
mine de rien donc c'était important de
le préciser
et puis puisqu'on parle de plumes
puisqu'on parle de plus vous vous
rappelez certainement de cette étude de
2018 si je ne m'abuse donc il ya deux
ans qui nous annonçait fièrement la
découverte de plumes
donc vous voyez des petites protoplumes
comme ça chez les acteurs aux orres donc
un petit thé rose or de la famille des
agneaux gagnate idée donc voilà à quoi
devait ressembler le bestiau ce n'était
pas très joli ça ressemble plus à un
gremlin volant qu'autre chose mais voilà
ils ont découvert ces petites
protoplumes qu'ils appellent pique nos
fibres juste pour pas appeler ça des
protoplumes mais bon bref ils ont
découvert toute une variété d'ailleurs
de morphologie de ces protoplumes vous
pouvez voir donc certaines qui sont
plutôt penas et d'autres qui sont plutôt
très filamenteuses comme des petites
touffes de poils et certaines qui
ressemble juste à des poêles tout simple
donc tout ça tout ça indique est très
fortement que les ptérosaures donc avait
des poils ce qu'on n'avait pas vraiment
face qui ce qui existait dans la
littérature depuis les années 70 l'idée
que les ptérosaures avec dédé
protoplumes mais ou des poils
parce que évidemment pour les petits
rose or on savait pas trop si c'était
des poils ou des plumes mais en gros ça
existait depuis les années 70 c'est la
découverte d'un spécimen au kazakhstan
mais en gros depuis c'était un peu resté
en stand by et cet article de 2018 avait
revigoré cette idée et il avait fait cet
arbre phylogénétique dans lesquels il
comparaît évidemment les dinosaures
d'un côté donc là les souris ce tient là
les ornithischiens et ils comparaissent
à aux ptérosaures et en gros il en
venait à la conclusion que bas même si
chez certains même si certes certains
ptérosaures on trouve pas de protoplumes
préserver il est quand même très
probable qu'à la base les l'ancêtre des
dinosaures et des ptérosaures donc
l'ancêtre des abbés métatarse alliant
avait lui
aussi des plumes donc l'idée selon
laquelle tous les dinosaures avaient des
plumes et même l'ancêtre des dinosaures
l'ancêtre commun des dinosaures et des
ptérosaures qui avaient des plumes
elle vient de cet article là
essentiellement voilà donc même si on ne
trouve aucune plume voyez que c'est pas
la peine de me sortir dans les
commentaires oui mais tel dinosaures on
sait de source sûre qu'il a pas de
plumer mashhad
oui c est pris en compte dans cette
analyse c'est bien là la puissance
d'ailleurs de cette analyse c'est que
ici vous voyez en noir c'est tous ceux
qui ont des écaillers uniquement des
écailles et vous voyez avec la en noir
vous voyez tous et toutes ces espèces là
dont on sait de source sûre qu'elles ont
des écailles
elles sont aussi dans cette analyse mais
le fait est que généralement les espèces
basale dans mitis tient par exemple donc
comme coup linda drôme et us par exemple
ou tianyulong confuciusi donc les
espèces basale dans 10 cas possède des
plumes ou psittacose or ici encore une
espèce basale possède aussi des plumes
ici du côté des sorts ischia on a
beaucoup d'espèces basale de théropodes
dont on sait qu'elles ont des plumes
comme suri minus comme sur umih mus par
exemple qui même si en fonction de la
croche dans le lent l'arbre du dans
l'arbre des théropodes reste une espèce
relativement basale quelle que soit la
place qu'on lui accorde
vous avez les espèces basale des
tyrannosauridés comme you tyrannus et
dix longues qui ont aussi des pour des
plumes
donc même le même si on sait que
quasiment aucun sauropodes même aucun
sauropodes pourtant pour autant qu'on
sache n'avait de plumes
ça ne change rien au résultat du fait
que les sauts risque rien son l'ancêtre
commun des sans escales et reconstitués
comme ayant eu des plumes
là ils ont même poussé le vice jusqu'à
avoir différents types de plumes donc
les mono filament qui sont des poils ce
qui ressemble à des brosses ceux qui ont
une petite touffe au bout donc le enfin
non ouais ce qui ressemble à des brosses
donc c'est le type 3 ici ceux qui aiment
petite touffe au bout c'est le type 4 et
ceux qui ont le 5 et 6 bassolé les
plumes d'oiseaux les vrais on va dire 5
et 6 et les vraies plumes d'oiseaux qui
sont ici voilà 5 et 6 donc les plumes de
duvet et les plumes de vol
enfin celle là encore elle est
symétrique donc c'est pas vraiment une
plume de vol sont pas poussé le vice
jusqu'à inclure les plumes asymétrique
de toute façon on sait très bien où
elles auraient été ses plumes
asymétrique elles ont été ici avec les
oiseaux c'est une reconstitution
phylogénétique avec utilisant une
méthode il me semble probabiliste
bayésienne bayésienne au maximum de
vraisemblance donc quoi qu'il en soit
voilà c'est ça maximum de vraisemblance
ici je vois donc c'est une méthodes
probabilistes basé sur des stats je veux
dire c'est quand même un peu plus
puissant que notre petit cerveau faut
dire ce qui est et ça inclut tous les
cas où il ya des écailles chez les
dinosaures donc c'est pas la peine de
venir me faire le la leçon dans les
commentaires que tous les dinosaures
n'avait pas des plumes
on sait que tous les dinosaures n'avait
pas des plumes eux le savent aussi mais
par contre lens être en commun des
théropodes l'ancêtre en commun des
ornithischiens l'ancêtre en commun des
dinosaures mêmes l'ancêtre en commun des
pierres aux arrêts des dinosaures très
probablement avaient des plumes
ça c'était la conclusion de 2019 mais il
ya un article qui vient de sortir
donc cette année bon il sera peu à la
bourre qui est une réponse à cet article
la qui s'appelle pas de protoplumes chez
les ptérosaures donc au cas où depuis
tout à l'heure vous vous excitez sur le
fait que j'appelle ça des protoplumes
voir des plumes tout court
voilà c'est eux qui appelle ça comme ça
c'est les spécialistes qui appelle ça
comme ça moi je suis pas spécialiste des
dinosaures ni des protoplumes pas du
tout mais voilà les spécialistes
appellent ça des protoplumes je connais
le mot pique nos fibres je trouve ça je
trouve ça difficile à écrire je trouve
ça difficile à prononcer
préfère protoplumes voilà donc bref eux
ils disent pas de protoplumes chez les
ptérosaures et leur grande leurs grands
arguments contre la présence de
protoplumes chez les ptérosaures c'est
qu'en gros ce qu'on voit enfin ce qu'on
verrait et qui aurait été interprétée
par cet article de 2018 comme des
protoplumes en fait ce serait des genres
de c'est ce qu'ils appellent des axes
des acti nos fibres île dont des actes
hinault fibre c'est en fait du produit
de dégradation de certaines molécules
qui se trouve dans la peau et qui forme
des genres de filaments et ses filaments
se fossilise ans en fait ça ressemble à
des filaments de protoplumes voilà donc
après ils peuvent s'organiser de
différentes façons en donnant des
petites touffes ou en donnant des trucs
benacer ou en donnant des petits et des
petits machins qui ont une touche au
bout enfin bref ça ressemble à au 3o
cinq types
enfin au moins aux trois premiers types
de protoplumes qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
donc eu ce qu'ils disent c'est que ce
serait éventuellement des acti nos
fibres il et ils disent non non pas de
protoplumes chez les ptérosaures bombe à
ce à quoi les auteurs de l'étude
originale de 2018 d'ailleurs j'ai dit
2018 mais apparemment c'est 2019 pardon
mais bref ce à quoi les les auteurs de
l'étude originale ont répondu dans un
article sobrement intitulé réponse a pas
de protoplumes chez les ptérosaures
d'ailleurs je souligne au passage que
toute cette dispute à la lieu dans le
journal nature's écologie en évolution
donc une autre sur cuzieu succursale du
journal nature's donc c'est pareil ça
c'est de la dispute publique à aaa avec
comité de lecture et un trait au facteur
d'impact
on se tire dessus ans en grand comité
quoi voilà ces réunions chez
l'ambassadeur et puis on amène le
bazooka
en gros pour dire ah si de nouveaux
benton tenez c'est vraiment un paléo
news placée sous le signe de michael
benton bref et donc dans cet article il
ils répondent à ces gens que en gros
voici un des spécimens qu'on a étudié
voici les picks nos fibres et voici les
actes hinault fibre il nous savons très
bien à quoi la cty nos fibres il
ressemble nous savons très bien la
différencier des pics nos fibres
allez vous faire voir voilà c'est leur
réponse je veux dire vous voyez ça prend
deux pages mais ça mais ça se résume en
on sait très bien faire la différence
entre des pics nos fibres et de l'acte i
know fibrine merci on n'est pas des
crétins et on n'a pas fait cette bêtise
voilà nous n'avons pas fait nous n'avons
pas commis cette erreur et par
conséquent il y à bien des protoplumes
chez les petits rose c'est ça leur
réponse je suis pas spécialement je suis
pas spécialiste delà de la question
mais bon 6e me disent qu'ils sont
capables
enfin qu ils ont vu qu'il y avait des
actes hinault fibres et qu'il y avait
des pics nos fibres et qu'ils savent
faire la différence
je vois pas de raison de douter de leur
bonne foi
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi abonnez-vous à
notre chaîne pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et à très bientôt
[Musique]